So we're taking this
weight vector of ws and
taking the dot product
with the feature weights.
If the weights are all zero,
it's always going to predict zero
which is actually the correct answer for
this NDP.
So this it's really easy to set
the weights so that that happens.
Is that the only way to set
the weights to make this happen?
>> No because in fact for each one
of those states, there's only two
features that are turned on and
there are different two features for
every state except for state zero so
you could be pretty clever about it.
So I think if you make the weight for
zero minus 1 maybe and
then make features one through six
one-half, that would get you 0 for
everything except state seven and
then state seven just needed to be 7.
>> y or a seventh?
>> 7.
7, good.
So in particular, this weight vector
times this feature vector is going
to give us, well minus 7 plus
0 plus 0 plus 0 plus 7, so 0.
For this other one, it's going to give
us minus 1, plus 0, plus 0, plus 0,
plus 0, plus 0, plus 1, which is 0.
So, yeah, so this is a weight vector.
So, not only can we represent
the value function, but
we can represent it in
multiple different ways.
It is multiply representable,
which I spelled wrong.
Multiply, which is spelled
the same as multiply,
but it's representable
in at least two ways.
>> Actually an infinite number of ways
because you take that vector minus 1,
one-half, 7,
the multiplier by any constant
including zero and then it will work.
>> Nice.
Multiplied by 0 and you get that first
weight vector that we talked about
anything else that we get were
multiplying 0 times a constant.
So in fact there's an infinite set
of weight vectors that all capture
the optimal value function,
which is also 0s.
And so, we have plenty of rope.
We should be able to
build a rope ladder.
>> Yeah, paying ourselves.
>> Ultimately that's actually what's
going to happen in this case.
But it seems quite friendly, right?
It's also tiny, right?
>> Yeah.
>> These are all things that would
seem like it should make it so
that it's really easy to get this right.
>> So then that's get it right.
>> Yeah, well so it turns out that
what Baird showed is that, if you
give it the right sequence of updates,
it will actually spiral out of control.
So let's take a look at that.
>> Okay.